across social media particularly on
Instagram and snapchat temptation is
everywhere
glamorous-looking accounts offering
get-rich-quick schemes it's easy money
it almost sounds too good to be true it
is
I mean want to make easy money they
think they're just handing over a bag
hot with their deals they don't realize
that they're not gonna see any of this
money at the end of it Don is one of
hundreds of fraudsters using social
media to tempt young people in
particular into handing over bank cards
and other personal information many of
the criminals post videos flaunting
their wealth effectively sticking two
fingers up to the authorities despite
the obvious risk that online offers
could be scams dan says there's no
shortage of those willing to take the
risk
the easiest way now is to go like
Instagram and type in instant cash or
something like that
and there's so many like following to
these groups that are advertising the
exact same thing that what you're trying
to do to people so you just never risk
that you're the fastest growing social
media fraud is that of the money Moo
where users are promised a cut of the
cash if they allow their accounts to be
used to launder the proceeds of crime
sometimes they do get paid but mostly
they get nothing or worse their details
are used to steal from them latest
figures for the bulk of last year show
almost 30 thousand money mules in the UK
around a third more than nine and a half
thousand were under the age of 21 it was
actually on Instagram where they reached
out to me Rochelle was just 15 when she
agreed to become a money mule the
criminals used her account but she got
nothing the bank even blocked her card
I felt really humiliated because I can't
believe that actually thought that I was
gonna get this money but I think people
are actually afraid to say that it
hasn't worked because they feel
humiliated and embarrassed because I
know my sibling got scammed my best
friend got scammed and a lot of my other
friends were gone
social media companies have been accused
of doing little to stop criminals
exploiting their networks Instagram said
criminal activity is not allowed on
Instagram and our Community Guidelines
clearly state that people must follow
the law we encourage people to report
content they think is against our
guidelines using our in-app tools
snapchat made a similar comment the
banks at least are being more proactive
joining forces using sophisticated
computer algorithms to pinpoint
fraudulent activity and the police are
warning young people just to get more
common sense when dealing with tempting
online offers dan says neither he nor
any of his fellow fraudsters have been
caught and as long as there are willing
victims he's not going anywhere if you
keep going online and you keep seeing
these accounts for several thousand
people on it that's like let's say seven
thousand potential people that would win
in your hundred when they record and
what's how many with a bank Odyssey
authorities tell us that under 25s are
six times more likely to fall victim to
social media scams than over fifties the
most tech-savvy generation seem far less
savvy when it comes to protecting
themselves from the online fraudsters
Mark White Sky News